bon alors si le sifflet 7 les assiettes
8 l'aspirateur d'offres global 10 le
téléphone vous croyez que nous allons
vraiment utiliser tous ses accessoires
de notre pièce monsieur disney mon cher
françois la réussite d'une oeuvre
théâtrale comme la nôtre dépenses la
qualité des détails
c'est pourquoi les accessoires et les
bruitages sont très importants quelques
faits les bruitages monsieur du snav
notre chère julie c'est très simple dans
une pièce de théâtre on peut pas
utiliser un vrai téléphone
donc il faut faire entendre le bruit
d'une sonnerie de téléphone au bon
moment c'est ça le brutal et dit
monsieur disney
vous croyez que casimir on sera capable
voyons ce très très simple tous les sons
ils ont enregistré sur une cassette oui
et casimir à une liste avec un numéro
pour chaque accessoire
il lui suffira de donner la liste des
accessoires dans l'ordre eh bien je
crois qu'il vaut mieux que j'aï l'aider
ah oui je crois qu'il vaut mieux aussi
ma chère julie venu vous avec moi je
vais voir les décors et bien tout à
l'heure un mois alors qu'ils aient mis
tout va bien ça marche
oui oui enfin non tu as des problèmes
oui voilà monsieur du snap m'avait donné
une liste d'accessoires en me demandant
de la ranger dans ma poche
enfin casimir tu n'as pas de poche dans
ta peau justement je ne suis pas un
kangourou alors j'ai perdu la liste est
maintenant je ne sais plus dans quel
ordre donné les accessoires dans la
pierre
heureusement il y ait la cassette des
bruitages nous aidera à reconnaître les
accessoires s'agira de reconnaître quel
bruit correspond à chaque objet facile
casimir
oui enfin ça va paraître tellement
facile monsieur écoute on va demander
aux enfants de nous aider d'accord les
enfants venus nous aider
venez b casimir l'an vous mettez
derrière l'état braila et trois tables
où il ya les accessoires de notre pièce
de théâtre
mettez vous bien en face des accessoires
je veux pas
c'est une série de bruit avec la
cassette de mon magnétophone et vous
devrez me dire quel est le bruit qui
correspond à chacun de ces objets tout
le monde a compris parfait mais
attention quand j'en verrai un bruit
vous ne répondrai pas tout de suite vous
laisserez les enfants qui sont chez eux
répondre à la fin du bruit simplement
vous me donner la réponse
tout le monde a compris c'est freddy
meyer habib en hiver j'attends premier
bruitages qu'est ce que c'est ça bon
alors c'est bien vous voyez attendu
alors maintenant la réponse est oui cet
accessoire voilà alors première foire
casimir qu'elle ait 20 corps prennent
votre téléphone
qu'est ce que c'est ça alors qu'à une
réponse
et la voilà premiers bruits le bouchon a
sauté deuxième bruit la limonade a été
versé dans leur aire de kazimierz la
limonade de kazimierz avons fait ce
bruit là avec le t3 sciandri d'arrêt qui
sont là alors qu'il a trouvé ce sont les
ingrédients très bien le dit c'est la
tante de casimir qui empile ses
assiettes de parmalat
oui c'est ça hein autres bruitages alors
qu'est-ce qui est sur la table là bas
c'est le sifflet à roulettes de casimir
à l'autre bruitages alors qu'ils
essaient sur le mois c'est la cie qui
vient de couper ou de boire ce morceau
de bois très bien caroline un autre
casino
[Musique]
réponse qu'est-ce que ça elle s'essaie
alors là bas on dit respirateur ici je
voulais légumes alors qu'est ce que
c'est et oui c'est le moulin à légumes
exactement c'est écouter en voilà un
autre
le moulin à café et vous êtes sûr oui
moi je ne suis pas sûr donc acquérir un
promontoire du téléphone du réveil le
réveil qu'on remonte c'est exactement il
est acquis et se réveille que ces
messieurs mon petit réveil montchapet
reconnu c'est ton petit réveil pour te
réveiller pour tenter toujours en retard
un poisson gymnastique les maternelles
et un autres bruitages c'est mon
trousseau de clés ça en plus casimir en
soi qui elle m'a fauché mais pour la
pièce le rendra tout à l'heure un autre
bruitages
tous d'accord oui c'est l'aspirateur
effectivement j'ai cinq ans chez eux
nous amis cherchent avec vous et trouve
à l'autre
mes tableaux
le rasoir comme un moratoire c'est bien
voilà je crois qu'on a passé en revue
tous les accessoires pour notre pièce de
théâtre que j'ai mis un bien îlots
casimir
je pense que comme ça lui fera bonne
accessoiristes alors c'est un beau
métier sonné tu sais la soie oui j'adore
ça je crois même que c'est le métier que
je préfère pantois ben non pas
exactement moi ce que je voudrais être
je te chanter ah oui françois chaud et
vous les enfants venez vite vous asseoir
[Musique]
ça c'est ce que je voudrais
l'inde
irem en petit ou très grand
je connais
être lait fourni les souris ont des vies
extraordinaires
je
audrey
vous plaît
explique ses mystères je voudrais être
très savants que d'être le secret des
choses
y at-il vraiment quelque part des
éléphants quelqu'un a t'il deviner ce
qu'on trouve au delà des étoiles il voit
ton parfois des lions des hommes
cya les moineaux les cargos et les
branches tout près
les caennais n'ont pas
là
les dauphins l'est parce qu'ils sont de
vrais mammifères
son
comme des poissons dans la mer je
voudrais être très savante connaître le
secret des chômeuses et y at-il vraiment
quelque part des éléphants risquent un
acte deviner ce coup trouve au delà des
épaules
il voit trop parfois des lions des
hommes ou des cigarettes
très
c'est ce que je voudrais
[Musique]
si ni vraiment
m
[Musique]
non